اتمنى ان يكون موجود بالجميع الدول
الاسلاميه وجميع الدول العربيه عم يفوت
المسلم والمسيحي والكردي والعربي من جميع
الاطياف عم يفوت وعم يستقبلوه بصدر الرحب
وعم ياكل ويشرب وبيصلي وبيشرب وبيمشي فطور
مجاني
اعتيادي المحافظات اللي ما عنده اللي ناجح
اللي منا منه يجينا ياكل وهذا ثواب لله
امن العالم كله
[موسيقى]
سليمانيه
هلا هي مبادره من من الناس اهل البلد ومن
المسؤولين البلد ومن المسؤولين هذا الجامع
التراثي العريق المبادره حلوه ولما بفوت
لهون الناس برمضان هلا اليوم اول يوم
رمضان كل عام وانتم بخير وكل الامه
الاسلاميه بخير عم بيفوت المسلم والمسيحي
والكردي والعربي من جميع الاطياف عم يفوت
وعم يستقبلوه بصدر الرحب وعم ياكل ويشرب
وبيصلي وبيشرب ماء وبيمشي حتى انا سمعت
هون من الناس اهل البلد يعني في شباب
معانا من اهل البلد انه بغير رمضان حتى
موجود عندهم تكايا عندهم بالجامع يومي
بيوزعوا الغداء للناس للعمال اللي بالسوق
للناس الفقراء اللي تيجي من غير محافظات
اي حدا جاي من غير محافظه ما عنده فلوس عم
يفوت بياكل وبيريح وبيصلي وبيمشي
اتمنى انه يكون موجود بالجميع الدول
الاسلاميه وجميع الدول العربيه يعني هذا
النموذج موجود يعني
بالدول الاسلاميه يعني مثلا العراق اهل
الكرم والطيب اهل الكرم والخير سوريا نفس
الشيء السعوديه نفس الشيء هالبدر برمضان
عم تنتشر عبادره ممتازه لانه نحن بوقت كل
الناس الله يكثر خيرهم
والله بالنسبه هذا الجامع من زمان يعني
قبل وهشه فطور مجاني
فطور مجاني
اعتيادي المحافظات اللي ما عنده اللي ناجع
اللي منا منه
وهذا ثواب امن لله امن العالم كله
بنغلاديش اكو محافظات ما يفرق هذا منو هذا
منو هذا منو ماكو فرق بين كردي عربي
هندي كذا كذا
اكل اعتيادي اكل يعني عادي
شو اسمه الواحد او الاثنين
خير العالم
اللي ما عنده اللي جاي هي هاي
[موسيقى]
صلاته الاف من الصائمين يفطرون في هذا
الجامع الكبير وهذا الفطور موجود في زمني
حضرتك احمد الشيخ حتى الان ماكو فرق بين
العرب والاكراد بين مسلم ومسلم اخر اي
واحد يريد ان يضيء الى هذا المطبخ
يؤتون الطعام